le plus intéressant est de les chasser
dans la région de leningrad à saint
pétersbourg nous sommes dans la partie
européenne de la russie assez loin de
l'épicentre du phénomène
bien sûr c'est très beau mais le
résultat dépend de beaucoup de facteurs
différents pour nous c'est assez
habituel de partir à 200 300 km de la
ville
nous savons que nous pouvons calculer le
lieu de son apparition
on est tous prêts à partir au moment
opportun
bien ça lui ça fait tellement longtemps
salut romain bonsoir tonia beaux jours
alors je me demande s'il ne manque pas
encore quels cas voilà natalia notre
guide
elle aime la broderie et conduit des
voitures de course le jour elle
travaille dans l'analyse de données
mais la nuit elle est chasseuse d'aurore
bel anniversaire c'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui et elle va le fêter
en chassant les aurores boréales la
météo n'est pas très bonne mais ça ne
l'arrêtent pas alors voilà les nuages la
partie grise on peut dire que c'est le
ciel clair la partie jaune c'est notre
problème mais y arriver prendra du temps
donc la partie dégagée du ciel va
changer ou de ton jeu depuis bruxelles
les aurores boréales sont la passion de
natalia c'est à saint pétersbourg il ya
six ans qu'elle en a vu pour la première
fois depuis elle voyage à travers le
pays pour en voir d'autres jeux ont
gagné nous étions sortie faire des
courses
quand nous avons vu une énorme couronne
d'aurores boréales juste au dessus de
nous c'était un spectacle incroyable des
éclairs de différentes couleurs juste au
dessus de nos têtes
en 2015 il y a eu un véritable pic
d'activité solaire il y a eu plusieurs
apparitions d'aurores boréales cette
année là à saint pétersbourg j'ai pensé
que ce serait super de réunir quelques
amis partageant la même envie d'aller à
la chasse
c'est ainsi que le groupe aurora hunters
a été fondé tout d'abord natalia a
convié ses amis
ces derniers ont fait venir les leurs et
ainsi de suite
leur groupe compte désormais plus de
mille chasseurs au total cette fois ils
s'aventurent à 150 km au nord de saint
pétersbourg sur les rives du lac ladoga
ils sont partis à 23 heures et pourront
passer la nuit entière à la chasse on y
arrive et voilà les étoiles les lumières
la lune mars vénus tout à la fois avec
nous taquiner c'est presque trop facile
n'est-ce pas non
voici leonid il est titulaire d'une
maîtrise de sambo et de combats au corps
à corps
et contrairement aux autres c'est un
vrai chasseur léonie csaj généralement
la bécasse loi et le sanglier six bleus
eux mais maintenant ils chassent aussi
les aurores boréales 1
la chasse aux aurores boréales c'est
comme la chasse aux animaux
on cherche des aurores boréales parfois
on en voit parfois on n'en voit pas tout
se passe comme une chasse ordinaire vous
sortez et attendait que quelque chose se
passe où volent pas loin mais ce n'est
pas toujours le cas
les émotions sont exactement les mêmes
vire à gauche
non non non non tu te souviens il faut
lever la sécurité et paul joue bras
gauche
leonid est aussi instructeur de tir
il a récemment fondé avec sa compagne sa
propre agence de voyages c'est une
petite boule de neige qui est devenue
une avalanche notre entreprise propose
de nombreux voyages depuis deux ans nous
emmenons des groupes découvrir le grand
nord russe
[Musique]
c'est un mouvement aller quelque part
voir quelque chose en particulier de
belles choses comme les aurores boréales
éclatant de mille feux j'ai vu du vert
du bleu du rouge du jaune
et tout cela se mélange
on fait attention
c'est là que j'ai perdu une roue et
c'est aussi là que la roue de romas à
déformer on a dû la réparer au marteau
une fois j'étais à 250 km de
saint-pétersbourg et le carter s'est
cassé lui la suit ma voiture est tombée
en panne il faisait froid et je n'avais
aucun moyen de me réchauffer mais j'ai
toujours un kit de soudure à froid et
nous avons réparé le moteur sur le champ
attention vas-y doucement voilà on les
voit les étoiles
regardez ça c'est aurions sur la route
ils doivent faire attention à plusieurs
indicateurs l'activité solaire
la vitesse du vent la nébulosité si
quelque chose ne va pas ils peuvent
changer de trajet sur les webcams on
voit déjà ça un petit arc verts
commencent à monter on a
il ya donc on peut vraiment s'attendre à
une petite erreur ce soit à un moment
donné nous avons réalisé qu'il nous
fallait tout avoir à portée de main nous
avons fait un site web avec tous les
diagrammes et les prévisions toutes les
informations sont disponibles
tout le monde peut utiliser le site
gratuitement et tout le monde peut
partir à la chasse avec noah
regardez les diagrammes vous voyez tout
est clair
nous choisissons certains repères et les
mettant en évidence avec les différentes
couleurs par exemple c'est en paramètres
particuliers passent au rouge
cela signifie que nous devons partir on
peut même voir les éjections de masse
coronale là l'origine des aurores
boréales et très éloigné de notre
planète
c'est le soleil les éruptions solaires
intensifie les vents solaires des flux
de plasma qui transportent des
particules chargées
ils atteignent notre planète en deux ou
trois jours et se voit attiré par le
champ magnétique de la terre
les particules entrent alors en
collision avec les molécules de gaz dans
l'atmosphère au pôle magnétique émettant
de la lumière
c'est ainsi que les aurores boréales
apparaissent dans l'hémisphère nord en
russie
il est beaucoup plus facile de les voir
au delà du cercle polaire
l'une des attractions touristiques les
plus populaires et le village de terry
berka dans la région de mourmansk une
légende chinoise dit que si vous voyez
une aurore boréale
vous aurez de la chance pendant un an si
vous concevez un enfant pendant une
aurore boréale l'enfant aura de la
chance tout au long de sa vie par
conséquent toutes les infrastructures de
terry berck à son consul en fonction la
plupart des maisons sont orientés vers
le nord et possède de grandes fenêtres
ou des toit transparent
des événements intéressants ont lieu ici
quand une aurore apparaît parfois les
gens proposent de l'argent aux
conducteurs pour qu'ils descendent de sa
voiture laisse-nous 30 minutes va te
promener un peu il fait moins 40 dehors
mais on s'en fiche
va te promener
[Musique]
nantes est bleu et vert les couleurs des
aurores boréales se sont le vert le bleu
et le rose c'est le vert la couleur la
plus brillante et la plus visible
alexandre travaille pour une société de
spectacle laser il ne filme les aurores
boréales qu'avec la caméra de son
téléphone
en ce moment nous peaufinons les effets
spéciaux pour un futur événement parce
qu'un client veut sa propre aurores
boréales privé il ne veut manifestement
parents voir autrement non suivant
alexandre peut donc voir les horreurs
dans son propre studio mais il a
beaucoup de mal à rester en place
oui c'est bon on laisse ça je suis un
chasseur je regarde les prévisions
je chasse les aurores boréales je veux
les avoir ma vie a beaucoup changé
maintenant j'ai besoin d'expliquer à ma
femme où je vais la nuit au début elle
voulait connaître tous les détails
maintenant elle comprend ce que je fais
quand elle se réveille elle va sûrement
in-stat g pour voir ce que je fais tu as
donc un alibi
oui je fais toujours des vidéo en time
lapse que ce soit des nuages ou les
aurores
[Musique]
sinon je fais des vidéos uniquement avec
mon téléphone je ne suis pas photographe
pour moi l'essentiel c'est de voir une
aurore boréale j'arrive sur place
j'installe un trépied je pose mon
téléphone je modifie les eaux et la
vitesse d'obturation j'active le mode
time lapse et me voilà en train de
contempler ce merveilleux phénomène
ces chasseurs ont parcouru la région de
léningrad de long en large
ils ont même dessiné une carte des
meilleurs sites pour observer les
aurores boréales
une carte qui sera bientôt disponible
une fois des gardes frontière sont venus
chez moi à viborg en général les
photographes de nuit se retrouve souvent
dans le collimateur de la police et de
citoyens qui pensent que nous faisons
quelque chose d'illégal
car il s'agit des inconnus qui vend
quelque part faire quelque chose en
pleine font de drôles de gestes avec des
bâtons il est difficile d'expliquer aux
gens que l'équipement est hautement
photosensible et peut faire des photos
de la voie lactée et des étoiles
la route est impraticable personnes à
déneiger les routes glacées neige sur la
route mais il faut bouger
[Musique]
mes amis et ma famille il me disait mais
tu es folle où tu vas les routes sont
mauvaises la forêt dangereuse
il ya des cerfs des ours poissy midi et
quelques années se sont habitués et ne
s'inquiète pas de la neige jusqu'à la
taille
[Musique]
nous devons partir tôt demain matin et
voilà que tous ces gens courent sur la
plage la moitié d'entre eux ne sont même
pas photographe la communauté aurora un
torse n'a pas pour objectif de prendre
de belles photos
c'est surtout pour se faire plaisir et
voir si on a de la chance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les aurores boréales que nous voyons à
ce moment sont très faibles
c'est dû à la faible activité solaire
les horreurs le plus bel apparaîtront
vers 2025
on pourra les voir dans le ciel de saint
pétersbourg elles seront très intense et
de couleurs très variées
il y a encore une chose importante à
propos de natalia
elle adore les chats
et moi je suis un char
chat natalia et moi vivons avec quatre
autres chats mais bien sûr je suis son
favori les autres elle les a trouvés
dans la rue
il était très malade l'un d'eux avait
même perdu un oeil
natalia a pris soin d'eux et leur a
donné une maison on parle constamment
d'aurore de vent solaire et de nuages
dans le ciel de saint pétersbourg dans
cette cuisine mais elle ne m'a jamais
emmené à la chasse avec elle j'espère
qu'en 2025
je verrai moi aussi des aurores depuis
mon balcon
[Musique]